[Musique]
mais tu es sûr masse
versailles crash bandicoot est revenu et
bon sens que je suis ravie crash
bandicoot est le premier jeu vidéo
auquel j'ai joué durant mon enfance
vers l'âge de 4 ans développé par
naughty dog crash bandicoot a su séduire
de nombreux enfants et même adultes sur
playstation 1 et aujourd'hui en 2017
à l'heure où je vous parle crash
bandicoot a enfin été remasterisé on
pourrait même parler de remake
je remercie donc sincèrement activision
et vicarious vdn ce pour m'avoir rendu
de sacrés souvenirs et si je peux me le
pt un peu j'ai platines les trois crash
bandicoot eh oui bref nous ne sommes pas
là pour ça aujourd'hui pour célébrer le
retour du fameux bandicoot je vous
propose donc trois théories sur la
licence de ce héros allez c'est parti
lors de mes heures de jeu sur ce remake
je me suis posé une question
comme vous le savez crash bandicoot
possède un scénario de docteur cortex
essaye de dominer le monde
un classique il commencera par créer une
armée de sbires animaux ou crash aurait
été le général mais crash fut au final
une erreur car il s'échappera et se
rebellera face à cortex pour récupérer
sa petite amie taounat et non ce n'est
pas beaucoup
coco est la soeur de crash et apparaît
pour la première fois dans le 2 ça ou
menacer sa petite amie bref flash va
donc vaincre cortex et ses plans
machiavéliques
cependant c'est là que la théorie entre
en jeu nous passons à crash bandicoot de
ou cortex apprend la présence de
cristaux dans le monde
il souhaite donc s'en servir pour
alimenter son arme il va se servir de
crash bandicoot pour les avoir et cetera
mais ça ne va pas marcher évidemment et
nous allons le vaincre à la fin encore
une fois mais maintenant nous passons à
l'opus 3 de crash bandicoot tous les
cristaux a été récupéré par crash et la
destruction du vaisseau de cortex a
libéré par mégarde ou kawka le jumeau
maléfique de akoua coûts et nous
apprenons quelque chose d'étrange dans
l'introduction de l'opus warped écouter
d'autres sources d'énergie sur cette
planète
je sais nous avons eu quelques petits
contretemps cas aucun mentionne le fait
qu'il n'y a plus de sources d'énergie
car cortex a laissé crash récupérer les
25 cristaux qui parsemaient la terre
dans l'opus 2 donc bah maintenant il n'y
a plus de cristaux donc plus d'énergie
pour détruire la terre nous sommes bien
d'accord sur le fait que dans crash
bandicoot 3 il n'y a plus de cristaux
sur terre c'est pour ça qu'au chaos cas
fera appel au docteur néo thropy mètres
de là chrono tornade afin de pouvoir
retourner dans le passé pour récupérer
des cristaux de l'ancien temps d'origine
en gros c'est pour ça que nous avons des
niveaux au moyen-âge sur la muraille de
chine en egypte avec les dinosaures
autant des pirates et j'en passe
cependant un type de niveau me perturbe
énormément et toute la théorie se repose
là-dessus
peut-être que certains ont déjà deviné
alors qu'en est-il de futurs frenzy et
de gone to more
ces niveaux semblent parler du futur de
crash bandicoot 3 il y à un cristal dans
ces niveaux
cependant comment est ce possible il n'y
a plus de cristaux sur terre ou kaoka
l'a dit et il faut justement utiliser la
chrono tornade de tropiques pour pouvoir
retourner dans le temps afin de
récupérer des cristaux avant leur
disparition
tous les niveaux de crash bandicoot
trois sont des niveaux du passé du
moyen-âge voir encore plus loin futur
frenzy egon tomorrow sont les seuls
niveaux futuriste du jeu pourquoi nous
sommes bien dans une ville composée de
gratte-ciel et de technologie alors
erreur scénaristique ou bien théorie que
l'histoire de crash bandicoot se situe
loin dans le futur
je ne sais pas ce qui voudrait dire que
futur frenzy egon tomorrow font partie
du passé
cependant le monde de crash bandicoot et
très verdoyant après tout crash visite
de nombreuses ruines lors de son épopée
alors peut-être est-ce la ruine de ses
niveaux du passé nous n'en savons rien
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ces
niveaux pose problème peut être une
erreur de scénario ou bien théorie du
futur à vous d'en juger
et tout ceci me paraît bien bizarre
[Musique]
cette théorie fait partie des plus
grosses questions de mon enfance et je
suis fou king heureux d'en parler en
vidéo avec vous nous allons parler des
dingues odile et doria roues mais nous
allons devoir écarter dingo dit pour le
moment
arias roux est un personnage introduit
d'ancrage bâches pour les nombreuses
équipes car il fallait un personnage de
même carrure que d'un god il puisque
c'étaient deux équipes de quatre
personnages cortex comparé à crach cocoa
brio tiny akouala kong mais d'un god il
est le seul de son espèce rilliard où
fut donc créé pour l'occasion pour être
comparé à lui
mais le problème étant que ce personnage
fait réellement partie de l'univers
crash bandicoot mais ne possède aucun
rôle scénaristique et il ne possède
aucun poids sur la balance
nous savons juste qu'il est du côté de
cortex alors qui est ce riz yarou connu
pour son ton dans crash bandicoot qui a
marqué mon enfance ou pardon j'avais
trop envie
revenons en au mystérieux personnage
dans les pilotes de crash team racing
il est dit que ding odile hommes de main
de cortex se serait mis à muter des
animaux comme lui et que ses créations
étaient à base de kangourou et de gori
exactement comme la composition de
briare ou brouillards ou serait donc
créé par dingo deal un gode il est un
personnage qui a du poids qui est
récurrent dans l'univers de crash et se
sert d'un lance flammes et semble être à
base de kangourou et de crocodiles
d'où le dingo deal on ne sait pas qui
l'a créé il est dit dans la vengeance de
cortex qu'il est une autre bizarrerie de
la nature créée par cortex dans sa quête
du parfait guerrier génétique
cependant le manuel de cravache dit
qu'il fut créée par need russe brio
alors on ne sait pas il serait même à
l'origine de la conception de ria roues
c'est un personnage intelligent fidèle à
cortex et manie très bien le lance
flammes
il l'aurait alors aussi créerez yaro
peut-être dans l'histoire de l'opus 1
car si nous regardons bien la
cinématique d'introduction du jeu nous
voyons sur une cage le nom de kangaroo
est à l'origine aviaire ou devait
s'appeler comme guérilla mélange de
kangourou et de gori cependant
contrairement aux autres la cage de
kangaroo évident interprétation du fait
qu'il n'a pas encore été créée donc d'un
god i ne fut donc peut-être pas encore
créé à ce moment là après tout d'un god
il est un mélange de deux races animales
comme rilliard ou alors que les sbires
de cortex dans l'opus 1 sont composés
d'une seule espèce animale
il cherche à fabriquer le soldat parfait
avec d'un god in et ce serait
perfectionner avec le temps et aurait
utilisé plusieurs espèces pour le
concevoir après de nombreuses
expériences passées à 20 go deal est un
homme de main important et ne passe pas
inaperçu et justement il aurait donc
conçu criard ou ce personnage de crash
bâche mais bon c'est théo et son
apparition qu'à la saga était beaucoup
négliger niveau scénario et c'est un
petit peu dommage c'est pourquoi je fais
mes théories
j'espère enrichir cette dernière
[Musique]
pour finir la vidéo j'aimerais vous
parler de la disparition de taounate la
petite amie de crash bandicoot cette
dernière fait partie de l'opus 1 et est
même le but final du jeu cependant
taounat ou disparaît complètement dans
les opus suivants elle est totalement
absente de crash bandicoot 2 et 3 et il
n'y a aucune raison valable
c'est d'ailleurs je pense pour ça que
beaucoup de personnes confondent taounat
ekoko qui elle apparaît dans l'opus 2 et
3 à linverse de tarnac qui n'est que
dans l'opus 1
alors vous allez me poser la question
pourquoi taounat disparaît de crash
bandicoot après l'opus 1 après tout est
sauvé par son crash bandicoot et sont
voués à vivre deux jours heureux et bien
nos amis japonais ont une petite théorie
avec laquelle je suis en accord et que
je vais vous développez à ma façon
d'abord dans la vraie histoire et il
faut savoir que taounat est une
représentation de pamela anderson qui
était une actrice célèbre dans les
années au crash bandicoot est sorti pour
la première fois elle faisait sensation
car elle était très sexy et justement
taona fut retiré du jeu après le premier
épisode à cause d'une plainte de la
directrice marketing de sony de l'époque
le personnage était soit disant trop
choquant et pas du tout adapté au public
visé qui étaient les enfants une
adaptation d'une actrice sexy
stéréotypes et par la princesse lampe
d'un coincé dans un château et qu'il
faut sauver ça n'a pas fait l'unanimité
awana fut donc apparemment refaite et re
modélisés mais le résultat n'était
tellement pas au rendez vous qu'elle fût
retirer complètement du jeu
alors maintenant pour l'histoire comment
se fait-il qu'elle ait disparu et bien
d'après les japonais mais ce n'est pas
officiel dans le reste du monde
attention c'est que tana serait parti
avec pain ce type et c'est même une
évidence
vous souvenez papin stricte de son vrai
nom john pin strip hellip autoroutes y
est un boss que nous affrontons lors du
premier opus et qui disparaît tout comme
tu en as après l'opus 1
il était inspire proche de cortex il est
dit qu'après que cortex et été vaincu
une première fois est parti à chicago
pour exploiter une entreprise
d'assainissement l'échelle de la ville
mais ce n'est pas un hasard si taounat
serait parti avec un strip crash et
immature et un peu débile dans sa nature
taounat ne l'aurait donc plus supporter
et serait parti avec un strip
après tout ce n'est pas quelque chose
d'aberrant cela correspond parfaitement
aux clichés de la fille très sexy qui
n'aime que les méchants garçons d'un
strip est un mafieux c'est aussi un
personnage très cliché leur union
accentue donc encore plus ce côté cliché
de la blonde hyper sexy sortant avec un
gros mafieux puissant tout ceci a été
imaginé par les japonais et j'ai envie
de dire pourquoi pas c'est une bonne
sortie porte aoun a tout à fait logique
et je préfère cent fois ceux ci a
simplement une disparition de
personnages non justifiés
scénaristiquement et vous qu'en pensez
vous crash bandicoot est le héros qui
symbolise mon enfance mon tout premier
jeu vidéo et je suis très heureux de
vous avoir fait une vidéo sur lui vous
n'imaginez même pas malheureusement
crash bandicoot fut un jeu qui n'a pas
été assez exploité les jeux de
plateforme de l'époque ne possédait pas
vraiment de scénario ou bien il était
bâclé et c'est le cas malheureusement
pour crash bandicoot et c'est pour ça
que des théories se font facilement pour
justement s'amuser à compléter la saga
et chercher une autre option et oui les
théories ne sont pas des affirmations et
pour ma part les théories dont je vous
parle servent à enrichir une saga et la
compléter je cherche à vous à ip en tout
cas suite au succès du retour de crash
bandicoot sur ps4
il se pourrait que d'autres jeux
apparaissent dans le futur hashtag futur
frenzy et je ne demande que ça j'espère
que mes théories vous auront plus merci
à ceux qui laisseront pas pouces bleus
qui partageront la vidéo n'hésitez pas à
me suivre sur twitter pour les plus
acharnés d'entre vous cet argot rock et
que le liner soit avec vous
[Musique]